bienvenue à ce verdict own une ville où
il fait bon vivre une ville placée sous
le signe de la prospérité
oui qui lève toi il ya des hommes de la
maison il faut que je te dise quelque
chose
ces hommes ont tué maman j'ai décidé de
demander à ta tante margaret de venir
s'installer avec nous dit qu'il a besoin
d'une mère ça va aller on va s'en sortir
monsieur log vous connaissez un
personnage du nom d'origine
cette année juriez si vous deviez de
l'argent la mafia ça expliquerait ce qui
est arrivé à votre faim ça les moulins
c'est la dernière fois que ce clown se
fiche de nous occupe toi ducos
nicchi
tous ces fumiers nous ont tous brillé
prendre des décisions en ce qui concerne
le bien-être de la famille c'est la
panique l'enquète progresse un mafieux a
été tué il ya quelques jours je suis
désolée d'apprendre cette perte celle de
sa vie je pense que lui aussi doit être
désolé je viens récupérer mon dieu
combien vous voulez combien je veux je
veux tout
il ne s'était jamais rien passé de
semblable ici c'est un endroit charmant
enfin c'est tout
k
vous voulez une tasse de café
[Musique]
je pourrais vous tuer en moins de deux
moi aussi je pourrais vous tuer au moins
deux ans